بلغ عدد الضحايا في عشر ولايات تركيه حتى
هذه اللحظه
1121 شخصا لقوم وسرعهم نتيجه الزلزلين
اللذين ضربات
ولايه كهرمان مرعش وكان لهما لهذا لهذين
ارتدادات واثار سلبيه في عشر الولايات خلف
دمارا كبيرا عدد الجرحى بلغ
76434 جريحا او مصابا عدد المباني المدمره
حتى الان والتي تم احصائها الى غايه
اللحظه
2,834 مبنى في عشر الولايات طبعا غالبيه
المباني يعني الحديث عن ان غازي عنتاب
وحرمان مرعش اكثر الولايات التي تعرضت
فيها المباني للدمار اولا لان كهرمان
مرعشيه المدينه التي
ضربها الزلزال الاول صباح هذا اليوم كان
بقوه
7.7 تجرح هذا اليوم في تمام الساعه 4:17
بتوقيت المحلي نتيجه هذه الزلزال ولايه
غازي عنتاب محاذيه تماما لولايه كهرمان
مرعش تضررت بشده وبعد زلزال الاول بربع
ساعه فقط 15 دقيقه كان هناك زلزال او هزه
افضل هزه ارتداديه بلغت شدتها 6.6 ضربت
ولايه غازي عنتاب ما ادى الى زياده حجم
الدمار في هذه المدينه وزياده عدد الضحايا
في تمام الساعه الواحده والربع بعد ظهر
اليوم ايضا زلزال اخر بقوه بلغت شدته 7.6
درجات ضرب ولايه كهرمان مرعش خلال جهود
فرق الانقاذ
للوصول الى العالقين تحت الانقاض ايضا هذا
الزلزال الشديد والمدمر ضرب او سلبا على
ولايه غازي عنتاب وبالتالي زاد من حجم
المباني المدمره في كلتا
[موسيقى]
الولايتين
زيدان كيف تسير عمليات الانقاذ وانتشار
الضحايا من تحت الانقاذ خصوصا مع ما ذكرته
يعني مع حدوث هزات ارتداديه والى اي مدى
المهمه صعبه جدا في ظل الظروف الجويه
السيئه التي يعاني منها او تعاني منها
مناطق شرق المتوسط في هذه الاوقات
نعم هناك عوائق عديده اهم مشكله الان
تعاني بالفرق الانقاذ هي الوصول الى
المناطق المنكوبه بعض الطرق السريعه حتى
هنا في تركيا قد تعطلت تماما بسبب الاضرار
التي حدثت في هذه الطرق في بعض النقاط ما
ادى الى تعطيل حركه الطرق والوصول الى هذه
المناطق المنسوبه الطريق الدولي الواصل من
انقره الى مدن الجنوب الذي يصل بدايه الى
اظن ثم غازي عنتاب وكهرباء مرعش